[Music]
another silex
but this one's open
what do you think another problem
why so cynical it might be something
good
trust me
it won't be
um
how do we get out of here terminal over
there
just give me a second i should be able
to get control from here
so dramonius has fallen
the victim of the master chiefs might do
not fool yourself he was not the best of
the banished not by any measure
it occurs to me that we have not been
introduced i of course
know of you spartan
your legend the fear you inspire is
admirable the hope you stir in the
hearts of your kind
misplaced
i want you to know my name too
to know my legend
how else will you beg me for mercy
i am esheram
war chief of the banished
this is my world now
and you
have little time remaining in it
[Music]
wow look at this place it's so
full of more monsters coming to kill us
you're gonna need to clearly somewhere
to land
incoming
on
animals
you can't
wow
this can't be happening
two
we're losing why are we losing
uh
[Applause]
uh
that's the last of them
is it safe is anything
don't answer that if you can find me
somewhere to hack in i think i can
guarantee this base will be safe for
your friend to land
let me see
the banister using a modification of the
covenant's battlenet protocol
pretty easy to push through and
done
i've removed this location from their
system
we're safe here
lz secure
[Music]
oh
solid ground
[Music]
as good as this feels
please tell me we can go
did you find the weapon you were looking
for
can we go hey
this is all her fault it isn't cortana
tell him
but it's classified
permission granted
i was created by dr catherine halsey to
mimic this installation security to trap
cortana for deletion
i was successful cortana's no longer a
threat and now she's going to help us
stop the banished
of course she is
i think i'm with you
i didn't even know what a banished was
an hour ago and even i can see the odds
aren't great yes
yes you should listen to her you're
gonna get us all killed oh this is
fascinating
you're trying to survive
but i was programmed to die
really
one person with a death wish wasn't
enough
well i was just figuring what i'm
supposed to wait
i'm picking up a unsc distress signal
location the source is four kilometers
from here
here is the distress signal's point of
origin
this is our current location
this was until two minutes ago a
banished forward operating base i say
was because now
it's ours
chief what is she talking about
now here's the cool part
there are more unsc forward operating
bases that have fallen into banished
hands
well pause they have paws
each one is associated with a territory
here is the location of the unsc signal
i've been tracking and here are two more
fobs
let's go let's go
what
[Music]
there
foreign